even if you did Lay It Down better that
just means that I personally need to
step my game up yeah so that I can you
know compete I'm gonna be honest though
it was tight as [__] before I could have
used a little straightening so now he
wants to compete with a corn star that's
like okay okay let's just let's just
like think about this now obviously this
is like treachery debauchery craziness
but imagine if that's like saying a
pickup basketball player needs to
compete with somebody in the NBA you
know what I mean it's like what like
that's like saying and this is just
based off of you know what they've been
going that's like saying a guy that's
like six foot it needs to compete with a
guy that's six like it's like what is he
supposed to he's a corn star you know
what I mean